like everywhere leicester is coming back
to life and while some choose caution
others are embracing renewed freedoms
this city experienced the longest
lockdown restrictions in the country
having guests at home was illegal here
for over a year
they're ready now not for a new normal
but the old one
i'm looking forward to actually
hopefully a lot more people have come
into the city as you can see i've got a
lot of empty stores around here so
i'm looking forward to it
with the latest easing of restrictions
people who get covered will still be
advised to self-isolate but it won't be
a legal requirement so those who feel
they can't afford to stop working won't
have to
myself personally you know i'm one of
the people that will just get on with it
you know i haven't got time being
self-employed i have to i haven't got
that choice really
we spread flu we spread germs we spread
everything every day
there's got to be a cut-off point for
this
or
the country's going to fold in on itself
but for some that means more chance of
catching a potentially deadly virus jen
who has autoimmune arthritis feels
freedom for others will create more
restrictions for her
it does feel like the vulnerable people
are being thrown to the wolves it does
just put people like me at more risk
when i go out and about because i'm
going to be really anxious about who
near me
potentially has something that is really
harmful
the vaccine does reduce that risk and
now an additional fourth jab will be
offered to the vulnerable and over 75s
this spring and most of those eligible
seem happy to take it yes no doubt i
know too many people that have not had
jabs at
all loads of them have come down with
the virus will you get the booster jab
before oh yes certainly yes does it
reassure you do you feel that's okay now
you can go out i do it it's it's a
different city now now that uh
apart from the days when you know you
can't move about a bit yeah
so a life unrestricted close and
bustling is coming back and for many
businesses including leicester's curve
theater it can't come soon enough i
guess there will always be people who
feel that it's you know a step too far
too soon but i guess our question would
be is when is the right time and i think
you know learning to live with this
virus um is is is is the only way
forward i mean covid has decimated the
theater industry
so the restrictions are over but the
virus is here to stay and for the first
time since it arrived we're going to try
to live with it as we lived before
jason farrell sky news